tous
[Musique]
une exposition qui
réunit sept grands
réseau touristique et le but du jeu
c'était que chaque association chaque
réseau présente une sélection de
photographies
[Musique]
mais si vous êtes dans une assemblée qui
représente les collectivités
territoriales nous voyons bien que cette
exposition elle porte lame du pays pas
simplement au travers du patrimoine
travers des activités qu'elles soient
artisanale qu'elles soient des activités
de pêche des activités d'élevage on a
cherché en fêtes a organisé l'exposition
en fonction d'un parcours plutôt
sensible
comme une sorte de voyage en france qui
s'organise et qui s'articule plutôt
autour des tannes chromique des
résonances thématique des compositions
avec des vues plongeantes dévide plein
ciel avec également une chromie un petit
peu particulière qui fait qu'on pêche
des rouges sur des bleus on revient sur
des blancs ce qui fait qu'on a pu
présenter aussi des paysages hivernaux
et tout ça pour montrer je suis rend la
diversité des paysages et la richesse
des paysages et des sites patrimoniaux
qu'on pouvait avoir en france
[Musique]
la chance d'avoir une franche magnifique
on a la chance d'avoir des associations
qui s'occupent avec des bénévoles la
valorisation des patrimoines que soit le
patrimoine immobilier les centres
anciens espaces naturels les graphiques
de france tout ça ça fait partie de
notre culture c'est ce que nous avons
voulu apporter sur les grilles du palais
du luxembourg pour que ceux qui passent
qui vient en me levant le matin ou
l'après midi puissent les découvrir et
redécouvrir un par un
[Musique]
patrimoine de ce patrimoine ancien
permet aussi de faire vivre dans ces
lieux le patrimoine vivant le spectacle
vivant la culture d'aujourd'hui et ça
aussi c'est le lien je pense qu'il est
important et pour toutes ces raisons je
pense que cette exposition en ce moment
a beaucoup de signification
ce qui est marquant c'est qu'à chaque
fois ce qui est présenté ce sont des
lieux de vie sont des lieux de partage
et je veux dire que c'est
particulièrement précédemment
[Musique]